سيداتي وسادتي الرئيس القادم
للولايات المتحدة دونالد ترامب لقد
تلقيت للتو اتصالاً هاتفيًا من الوزيرة
كلينتون ، حيث هنأتنا بأن الأمر
يتعلق بنا بفوزنا وقد
هنأتها وعائلتها على حملة 40 صعبة للغاية
أعني أنها قاتلت  من
الصعب جدًا الآن أن تلصق أمريكا
جراح الانقسام ، وأتعهد لكل
مواطن في أرضنا بأن أكون
رئيسًا لجميع الأمريكيين وهذا
مهم جدًا بالنسبة لي لأولئك الذين
اختاروا عدم دعمي في الماضي
الذي  كان هناك عدد قليل من الأشخاص الذين اتصلت بهم
للحصول على
توجيهاتكم ومساعدتكم حتى نتمكن من العمل
معًا وتوحيد بلدنا العظيم
للعمل معًا ، سنبدأ
المهمة العاجلة لإعادة بناء أمتنا
وتجديد الحلم الأمريكي ، لقد كان
ما فعلوه  استدعاء حدث تاريخي ولكن لكي
تكون تاريخيًا حقًا ، يتعين علينا القيام
بعمل رائع وأعدك بأنني
لن أخذلكم ، سنقوم بعمل رائع
ويمكنني فقط أن أقول أنه بينما
تنتهي الحملة عن عملنا  في هذه الحركة هو الآن
مجرد بدايتك